بيظل الازمه القائمه بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين حول رفع سقف الدين العام
البالغ واحد وثلاثين تريليون و400 مليار
دولار يتعقد المشهد خاصه مع اقتراب
الحكومه الفيدراليه من الحد القانوني
المسموح به للاقتراض من اجل سد عجز
الميزانيه
الخلافات واضحه بين الحزبين فالجمهوريون
يطالبون بخفض الانفاق الحكومي في عدد من
القطاعات بينما يرى الديمقراطيون ان خفض
الانفاق سيؤثر على قطاعات امنت لهم عددا
كبيرا من الاصوات في الانتخابات السابقه
الانتخابات السابقه باصوات الشباب وذوي
الدخل المنخفض وهو لا يريد ان يخسر هذا
الامتياز قبل الانتخابات المقبله المصيريه
بالنسبه للديمقراطيين
الجمهوريون حددوا بعض المجالات المحتمله
للاتفاق وهي اصلاح التصاريح لمشاريع
الطاقه والبنيه التحتيه والغاء الاعفاءات
الضريبيه للطاقه النظيفه تجديد متطلبات
العمل لبرامج المساعدات الفيدراليه قطاع
التعليم والبرامج الاجتماعيه الغاء اموال
كوفي 19 غير المنفقه وامام هذه المطالب
يحاول الديمقراطيون فرض التعديل الرابعه
عشر في هذه القضيه الخلافيه منعا لتقييد
سقف الدين باي تخفيضات قد تؤثر على
شعبيتهم في الداخل
يجب على الرئيس ان يلجا الى التطبيق
التعديل الرابع عشر لا للمفاوضات مع من
يريد ان تتخلف الولايات المتحده عن دفع
ديونها نحن دائما نفي بالتزاماتنا لا
لتخفيض سقف الدين العام هذا امر غير مقبول
انا وزملائي وقعنا على وثيقه تطالب الرئيس
بتطبيق التعديل الرابع عشر الان
استخدام التعديل الرابع عشر سيفتح تحديات
قضائيه كبيره امام البيت الابيض الامر
الذي يتخ
وف من بايدن الذي يحاول ان يتفاوض في
الساعات الاخيره مع المحافظين للتوصل الى
حل يمنع الولايات المتحده من التخلف عن
تفعيل ديونها سليمان العربيه واشنطن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات